this is north korea's biggest
intercontinental ballistic missile
state media has now released this video
of the test calling it a new type icbm
leader kim jong-un personally oversaw
the launch saying the test will deter
any potential military moves by the us
south korea reacted immediately
conducting a live fire test of multiple
ballistic and tactical missiles
military is closely monitoring a north
korea's military movement and confirmed
that we have the ability and readiness
to accurately strike the origin of a
missile launcher
thursday's launch shows north korea's
nuclear capability has advanced the
missile flew higher and for a longer
time than any previous tests the size of
this means that it can fit a lot more
inside of it so we're likely looking at
a missile that can carry for example
more than one warhead
right so you could strike multiple
targets with a single missile
the timing of the launch is also
significant because of the world is kind
of fixed on the ukraine crisis
that either north korea is trying to get
a friend to refocus attention on his
self
or
he thinks that because that we are so
preoccupied that it's
they may incur less repercussions uh
because of
all the bandwidths that ukraine is
taking a break
the test is being seen as a major
escalation the u.n security council will
meet on friday to discuss the launch
for years attempts to dismantle north
korea's nuclear and ballistic missile
programs have failed and kim jong-un has
made no secret of the fact he wants his
country to be recognized as a nuclear
state
florence louis al jazeera